breaking news for you here in the UK in
British politics and Boris Johnson has
just released a statement we want to
bring that to you it's to do with the
Privileges committee he says I've
received a letter from the Privileges
committee making it clear much to my
amazement that they are determined to
use the proceedings against me to drive
me out of parliament while I'm joined in
the studio now by our correspondent Liz
Bates to bring us more on this it is
I've been just quickly flicking through
it Liz it's an extraordinary statement
well you haven't even got to the best
bit because he's standing down as an MP
he is triggering an immediate
by-election in his constituency of
Uxbridge and South ruislip so the former
prime minister Boris Johnson will no
longer be an MP and this is in response
to what he sees as as a stitch up by the
Privileges committee